[Music]
my name is Jim Mian I'm the Managing
Partner of PDT the benjin's
old-fashioned it's our signature
cocktail it's a simple drink it's made
with Angostura bitters for roses yellow
label bourbon it is fat washed with a
bacon made by a gentleman named Allan
Benton who's a pig farmer in Tennessee
I'm going to serve it over a clear ice
cube that's harvested by Long Island ice
sculptor Shintaro Okamoto beyond just
the fixed cost of the ingredients the
environment in which you're drinking
affects the cost of the cocktail my name
is Julio at the sunny soda shop at
Mondrian today we're looking at the
chinotto it's made from Woodford
small-batch bourbon after that measure
out the miracle of Sardinia half an
ounce of the yuzu juice out of each yuzu
fruit you only gets a teaspoon of juice
so you can imagine how much you need to
make a whole bottle and a touch of
sparkling lemon soda from Italy as well
being on a rooftop having 360-degree
views you know that also adds to the
cost of what you're drinking
[Music]
my name is Chris Marshall I'm the head
mixologist at a Patek the drink that
we're going to make today is called paid
vacation so the first thing I'll do in
my pint glass I'll muddle up a few
cucumber rounds after that I'm going to
add the sour mix we will use a pineapple
and we will smoke it with hickory wood
that has to be done several hours before
I'm also going to add an ounce of both
mezcal as well as tequila I finish it
with a dash of habanero bitters it's
just sort of like if you purchase a
painting you're not just buying the
paints in the canvas you're buying the
creative spirit of the artist
you